five four three
two welcome to the new icarly
feels so good to have icarly back
in our lives fans were freaking out over
the trailer
jerry you said damn it and everyone
freaked out
how are you feeling where are you
anticipating that i feel
great i feel like i can it's like a
genie out of the bottle
i'm gonna start cursing like a sailor
i'm gonna blow people's minds
we know what the people want now
apparently they just want me to be a
foul mouth
they just want you to say damn it and
drink beer that's right
they want the real deal finally spencer
he's an
animal let out of the cage damn it it
was
so much fun to see the trailer because
it definitely like it said
feels like the show that we grew up with
and loved but a little bit more mature a
little bit edgier
how would you feel that icarly has
evolved
when the conversation first got started
we were we didn't know
what it would even be and none of us
really wanted to do
the same show or a kids show and we just
were like
it's been so long the kids that loved it
are now in their 20s why don't we at
leanne
leanne we're like we didn't want to
abandon you
like why you would have been like oh
they're just doing it for kids again oh
but that's what i was worried about i
was like wait a second i don't have kids
yet i'm in that weird awkward stage
where i loved the show but i don't have
anyone to show
this to so would you say that this is
for that specific audience specifically
at 100
like yes absolutely people are weirdly
loving this
freddy is a stepfather like blew
everyone's mind when they first read it
and then we see him
in this kind of paternal role what was
your reaction when you found out that he
was gonna be stepping into this parental
role
in a way i was excited because it was
great knowing that my character was fast
forwarding to being a father to an 11
year old whereas
i'm only a father to a three and a half
year old and a two-month-old so i feel
like
i was giving myself the chance to kind
of get a cheat sheet of what it's like
to have an 11 year old
turns out it's harder than i thought 11
year olds are tough
especially when they're played by jayden
triplett who is this
amazing combination of like sweet and
adorable but also
so wise beyond her years and a
firecracker and
is not just sassy to freddie she's sassy
to
everybody we saw freddy flirting with a
girl we saw
carly on a date does this mean that the
romantic potential between
freddie and carly is over or is there
still room for something to spark
you know in in your late twenties one of
the biggest questions
that a lot of people are figuring out is
who am i gonna do life with
and how does my day what i'd say every
morning nathan
who am i going to do life with yeah
that's the question
because you're still in your late
twenties you've never seen a new life
with me
so i think yes that that is the uh one
of the key questions that i think we ask
on this show is how does dating
work especially for carly being this
like she's still a celebrity
she's this internet famous person how
does that affect her dating life and
you know freddie comes to the table with
a lot of baggage how does that affect
his dating life obviously we see in the
trailer
not well there's a lot of uh runway to
explore dating relationships but of
course
they still live right down the hall from
each other they're still best friends
they're still spending a lot of time
together
anything can happen anything i had so
much
fun seeing all of our familiar faces
peppered throughout the trailer and can
i just say that the actress who plays
freddy's mom
has not aged freddy i put your warm milk
in your thermos next to your bed
very sheer hilarious as ever and
apparently found the fountain of youth
somewhere in the last nine years
not fair not not so for this face but
dang
do i look good you look great
will we find out where gibby is that's a
great question
a good question i don't know i don't
know either
i think i don't know the answer to that
yet i think what's great is that's the
most
gibby thing right now is just that
question of
where is what's gonna be up to basically
you know it
speaks to the larger thing which is you
know when when we were doing this
we didn't want to abandon the world that
had been created we wanted it to be
that weird sort of satirical absurdist
world
but what would that look like now in the
modern internet age
like there are people that are going to
come back from the past like you know
they're
you're going to see nora dershleit
you're going to see principal frank
like these characters they're not gone
like they still exist in this world
there is a canon world that exists and
it's
definitely you just never know well and
that's the thing is
we know that jeanette mccurdy is not
taking part in this series but
sam is still in this universe will we be
getting an explanation as to where sam
is and and what her relationship status
is with carly and freddie and spencer
today
yes the pilot touches on it it it will
be addressed
but it's not something that we go too
deep into
just because you know we want to respect
jeanette's wishes you know she's decided
to move on from acting and she's doing
great
in her own world and and we're super
proud of her and she's part of this
family forever
but that also gives us space to sort of
get new characters in
and and have new unexpected story lines
and voices and
but yeah it will be addressed but if
jeannette were to see how amazing the
series is because it looks like so much
fun and she
suddenly is like you know what i'll come
back for an episode is the icarly
elevator door
open to her i mean that elevator door is
always up
it never closed but again we want to be
respectful of of her and the decisions
that we made so obviously you know no
pressure
of course but whatever she wants to do
we love her that's that's all she needs
to know last question for you jerry
how many spaghetti tacos have you eaten
since the show came back well
when i was getting ready for the show i
needed to carbo load before
nathan put me on a strict keto diet so i
was up to about
six spag tacos a day it was gross
it got gross it was just a lot of it's a
lot of carbs
it was a lot of carbs yeah it didn't do
wonders for my gut
and it didn't do wonders but you know
what you guys are doing wonders for all
those that are my age so i just really
appreciate it i'm so excited for the
show to come back thank you both
you